right off the bat I can tell you guys
one reason why this purge is better than
the last one cause it doesn't have this
stupid [ __ ] King the purge anarchie
I'm proud to tell you I like this movie
I've been liking like almost every movie
this summer which makes it look like I
like everything but that's not true
there are some movies I really don't
like this just doesn't happen to be one
of them first off it's an improvement
over the first film by far the first one
sucked okay that was a letdown this one
what's really neat about it is they
actually did a story of what we pretty
much wanted to see in the first one it's
not a home invasion movie this movie
takes place out on the streets where you
really get a feel the atmosphere you get
to actually feel the world of the purge
it actually made it scarier it made it
more menacing not only because you can
do more with it it's just actually being
a part of the moments isn't the first
one there are no home this one there
outside of home so they have nothing to
protect them they have to be on the run
all the time it kind of reminded me of
like a little bit of Walking Dead a
little bit of escape from New York
we're like society is the bad guy I
thought it was actually really neat
because like the first one had a great
concept but I didn't appreciate its
execution at all good [ __ ] kid I mean
the kids smart enough to build like a
baby robot with a camera in it but he
can't [ __ ] make smart decisions and
his fault that dad's dead you haven't
seen the first Berchtold I ruined it for
you yeah well they I just really love
about it so you got more of what you
actually wanted so the film actually had
a menace about it it was actually pretty
intense at times I mean don't get me
wrong there's some bad things about it
for sure I mean at times it's pretty
predictable like let's put it like this
however you're gonna guess is gonna die
you're probably right this movie
essentially has like three different
stories and they all come together
through a
series of events and then that's when
breaking a hack - it all takes place out
on the streets where they have to
survive these twelve hours and in that
that's where it's a little interesting
like the character setup of this movie I
appreciated that context the intent more
than I did the actual writing itself I
mean it's better writing than the first
one for sure but a part of what I
probably the only about the writing
probably had a lot to do with the acting
this guy he plays the boyfriend in the
group - a beautiful girl this guy is um
I don't really like his acting too much
to be honest at times it's raining
scrims someone where a character is
really supposed to be a strong performer
in this movie I thought they got someone
who was not that great so II something
or another place like the the youngest
one of them all she's the daughter to
one of these people there and she is
she's pretty bad she's pretty bad
ya know like I was like damn girl you
are just reading from a script right now
you have rehearsed this and you are
practicing exactly word for word how you
rehearse this it seems very artificial
Zoe but the real [ __ ] star of this
movie this dude was the [ __ ] Frank
Grillo he is one of the main reasons you
got to watch this film he is [ __ ]
awesome he's a man who's out for
vengeance you know he's out for
vengeance you're not exactly sure why I
mean whatever you guess is the reason
and then they finally reveal it towards
the end it's that is why but he was like
a leading star like who is this guy I've
never seen him before I thought he was
like the [ __ ] so much I [ __ ] if he
shat on me I'd be like that is some
awesome [ __ ] badass a whole other level
intense and caring and you wish he was
your father basically yeah the adventure
is intense the adventure is scary at
times it delivers on good violence and
there's some clever to us some some
clever stuff in there like good times I
was like this film's clever I guess the
point I'm trying to convey is I thought
it was a little clever let me get
straight to the point here all in all
I gotta say the purge anarchy actually
got it right now there's some people
saying I don't have a rating system I do
it's got a right or got it wrong
problem is evident saying got it wrong
lately so people don't realize it
whatever anyway thanks for checking out
my video guys why don't you go ahead you
know scroll that comment box below and
tell me what would you do on the purge
and I want you to be just as filthy as
youtube comment box possible other
people will be like you know tread
lightly no I want you guys to purge on
the comment box it only sounds like a
goddamn [ __ ] joke when you say purge and
last but not least you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews or
videos is out go ahead and click on this
button by my dick to subscribe that's
right
dick let me tell you something about
this little arrogant he purges with
ladies and my ladies I mean hookers
every not may be illegal in California
but he don't care and now he has a chi
chlamydia